conforme a lo que había dispuesto el
kreming ha empezado el referéndum para
anexionar a Rusia las dos repúblicas
populares de doñez y también los
territorios ucranianos que son las
nuevas conquistas de Vladimir Putin
jerson y parte de la región de saborilla
en la votación se han seguido algunos
procedimientos poco ortodoxos Como por
ejemplo llevar las urnas casa por casa
acompañadas de hombres armados para que
la gente pueda votar desde el extranjero
se ha criticado duramente este
referéndum diciendo que no tiene ninguna
vanidad legal de hecho tampoco va a
haber prácticamente observadores
internacionales pero Rusia insiste en
que quiere conocer el parecer de las
personas que viven en esas regiones
del este de Ucrania pocas sorpresa se
pueden esperar Respecto a los resultados
más todavía cuando ya los medios rusos
están empezando a divulgar las primeras
proyecciones que arrojan un respaldo de
entorno al 97% en regiones respecto a la
unión con Rusia una Unión que parece ya
inminente